[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the youtube algorithm
really notices me
the xenogenesis trilogy aka the lilith's
brood trilogy is a series of science
fiction books written by one of the
greatest science fiction authors of all
time octavia e butler
now to even talk about this book series
a little bit i'm gonna have to give some
minor spoilers so if you don't want to
know anything about the xenogenesis
trilogy probably don't watch this video
this series has so many intriguing ideas
essentially through nuclear bombs
humanity ends up destroying itself uh
rendering most of the world to be
utterly uninhabitable
a race of aliens known as the o angkali
managed to save some humans
and they put them in stasis aboard their
giant
biological spaceship which is not quite
animal not quite plant
and
not quite asleep not quite conscious
these aliens are able to alter things
about the humans they make them
resistant to diseases they make it so
they no longer have cancer the ones
they'd rescued from earth would now live
extremely long lives and for most of
their lives they would look young
as the oenkali healed the rescued humans
and stasis they repaired the earth
making it once again inhabitable for
life
so all of this seems good the oh and
kali
seem benevolent this all seems like some
great act of cosmic
altruism
but of course it's not
the ohankali aren't doing this out of
altruism
they have a very specific reason for
doing what they're doing
and i'll explain why
life
perpetuates
itself
biologically speaking the goal of life
is to spread its dna
to multiply
now we've all seen the classic sci-fi
horror movie alien where the xenomorph
lays its eggs
inside of a host and the chest burster
comes out and it grows into a
full-fledged alien and that's how the
creature perpetuates itself that's not
exactly what's going on here but it is
about the perpetuation of dna the o and
kali themselves would call it trade
and hope you understand i have to tell
you something about the oh ankali and
their nature
so naturally there are three owankali
sexes they're male
they're female and there are ulue
the uloi have the ability to store and
alter the dna of others
what the oh ankali have done
continuously throughout the eons of
their existence is merge with different
species
and in the process that specific species
would be forever changed and so with the
ohankali and they would forever be one
and this is the fate they intended for
humanity as well
so in a sense humanity would no longer
exist
for their children would be
one kali
so this book series follows the last
surviving humans
as they come to terms with the fact that
they will likely be
the last humans as they see humans at
least
so this book has a lot of really
interesting themes and ideas
of course it brings up the question
what even is a human
but it's also about oppression and
ostracization
and being different and being feared for
those differences
it's about humanity's tendency to hold
on to archaic things
and resist progress for fear of change
so the aliens seek to trade with
humanity and in the process humanity
would be forever changed
but this series also acknowledges that
in doing this the owen kali have taken
agency away from humanity and that in
and of itself
is a terrible thing
yes they saved humanity meaning they
kept them from dying
but they also enslaved them and took
away their sense of being in control of
their own fate and of their own destiny
and to clarify what i mean i have to
talk about another slight spoiler the o
and kali have removed humanity's ability
to have children on their own through
male to female contact the only way that
humans can actually produce offspring is
by using uloi to mate and the ohankali
determine who gets pregnant and when now
of course there's plenty of humans that
don't want to mate with uloi but if they
choose not to they're condemned to live
out the entirety of their long lives
with no children which some of them are
okay with a lot of them aren't
so this series is one of the most
intriguing
and weirdest series that i've read in a
long time and i say weird in the best
way possible because i love
weird stories
i really enjoyed the themes of how do we
rebuild society and avoid the mistakes
of the past i always enjoy themes like
that in books and i also love the
concept of biological technology in
science fiction the alien vessel and the
way it functions i found to be
particularly interesting and of course
the nature of the ooloi and their
forever changing existence
and their existence in relation to
the biological technology that they
possess i also found to be very
interesting biological technology is a
concept that's really intriguing to me
and it's actually at the center of my
upcoming new graphic novel which i'm not
ready to talk about yet but i've always
loved the concept and i love the fact
that it's at the center of this trilogy
another interesting thing about this
series is yes aliens did save the humans
yes they did fix the earth repair the
damage that we had done to the earth and
to ourselves
but also there is this level of
condescension on the aliens part whereas
they kind of look down on humanity and
they kind of think they could never
survive on their own well maybe that's
true but to take away the free will of
the human species is essentially to
destroy the human species
now it is mentioned that the reason
these aliens chose to save humans
specifically was because there were
certain characteristics in humanity that
they found very
attractive essentially but the curious
thing about this is in doing what
they're doing in quote unquote trading
with humanity merging with humanity they
may be destroying the very thing that
drew them to humanity in the first place
now that being said there is a more
solid practical reason that these aliens
sought out humanity specifically but i'm
not gonna completely spoil that for you
unlike the last book i talked about on
this channel the killing star you
totally can get this book series as an
e-book if you want it's readily
available so octavia e butler is just
fantastic and i definitely plan on
covering more of her books in the future
if you enjoyed this video make sure you
like and subscribe for more quinn's
ideas thank you guys so much for
watching
[Music]
[Music]
you